فبعد كل التحديات في 2022 يتفائل مصنع
السيارات بمبيعات افضل العام الجديد ربما
لاحظ كثيرون غياب السيارات الجديده
وارتفاع اسعار المستعمله
والاولى قد تعود والثانيه قد تنخفض
اسعارها هذا التفاؤل الحذر جاء مدفوع
بالتوقعات ارتفاع المبيعات في الصين وهي
اكبر سوق للسيارات عالميا وتزايد مبيعات
الطرازات الجديده خاصه الكهربائيه ايضا
الانفراجه ولو جزئيا في ازمه الرقائق دفعت
بكثير من التوقعات الايجابيه في سوق
السيارات تابع المزيد عن هذا الموضوع من
الولايات المتحده مع زميله هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
انها سنه ليست ككل السنوات في عالم
السيارات المصانع بعيده جدا عن هذه
العاصمه اقوى عواصم العالم لكن كل سياره
تصنع وكل سياره تباع سيصنع صداها هنا في
اروقه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
سنه 2012 كانت اسوء السنوات في سوق
السيارات هنا منذ 2011 اي ما بعد الازمه
الكبرى ولكن صانعوا السيارات وعلى راسهم
فورد و جنرال موتورز متسائلون بامكانيه
التعافي في العام الجاري ووصول المبيعات
الى 15 مليون سياره لكن التفاؤل حضرتك جدا
في امواج التضخم والحروب ما زالت تضع هذه
البلاد والعالم في قلب العاصفه
[موسيقى]
التحسن في امدادات اشباه الموصلات وفي
مشاكل الامداد وبوادر الانحسار في مد
التضخم كلها تدفع للتفاؤل لكن السيارات
الامريكيه تواجه التنين الصيني لا سيما في
مجال السيارات الكهربائيه وكالعاده يعلن
الى مصر مفاجاته في الوقت المناسب ويعلن
تخفيضا بنسبه 20% على اسعاره اشهر
السيارات الكهربائيه الامريكيه تسله يا
صباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن
رغم التحديات التي انتقلت من عام 2022 الى
العام الجاري تشير توقعاته الى ان سوق
السيارات العالميه سينمو بنسبه 4% ليصلها
عدد السيارات الى 74 مليون سياره وهو اقلب
حوالي 8% عن مستويات عام 2019 اي قبلا
اندلاع ازمات الوباء والطاقه والرقائق
والحرب وغيرها في الصين رجحت اكبر مؤسسه
لصناعه السيارات ارتفاع مبيعات السيارات
في البلاد بنسبه 3% لتصل الى 27 مليون
و600,000 سياره في عام 2023 اما في
الولايات المتحده توقعت شركه جنرال موتورز
احدى اكبر شركات السيارات في العالم ان
تنتهي مبيعات السيارات في العام الجاري
عند 15 مليون وحده كما انه من المتوقع
تسجيل معدل النمو بخمسه بالمئه في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي 27
رابطه التجاره الحره الاوروبيه والمملكه
المتحده لتصل الارقام الى 11 مليون سياره
[موسيقى]
ومع فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا
صحفيه في قسم اقتصاد سمر يسعد صباحك سمر
اهلا بك هل بالفعل هناك بوادر تعافي في
قطاع السيارات بعد ازمه الرقاقات التي
شهدناها او رقائق والتضخم ايضا
من اخر السنه الماضيه وبدايه هذا العام
الجديد بلشت شويه تنتعش هذه الاندستري او
هذه الصناعه مره ثانيه البارحه حتى يتسرحت
انه الانتاج راح يفوق انتاجها في 2019 ما
قبل الجائحه باكثر من مليون سياره لانه
شويه في انفراج بازمه الرقائق الالكترونيه
اللي هي يعني هناك تقريبا 1,200 رقاقه قبل
متوسط بكل سياره هذه
مثل ما تعرفون تكلمنا عنها سابقا انه
الازمه اللي صارت في السنه او الرقائق
الالكترونيه هي اللي ادت بشكل اساسي الى
تعطل فصول الشحنات من السيارات
طيب سمر اليوم في ظل هذا التعافي نوعا ما
في ما يتعلق بالرقائق هل يمكن الحديث عن
تعافي مستقبل السيارات الكهربائيه في عام
20 23 بحكم انه انظمه ودوائر الامل كانت
تعتمد بشكل كبير على رقائق هذا صحيح اليوم
مو بس ما سالت الرقائق اليوم هناك ايضا
وعي واقبال اكثر على السيارات الصينيه
خصوصا في البلدان اللي يعني مكرش غنيه
مثلا بالاردن اخر مره نزلت كانت منتشره
ولانه هي منتشره في في لبنان في مصر في في
دول المغرب العربي لانه هي منتشره بكثره
يعني موجوده بكثره في الناس يعني تكون
صدرنج حتى بالنسبه لي مثلا بي ام دبليو او
غيرها كان هناك الكثير من سيارات بي ام
دبليو الكهربائيه والناس عندها اي اكثر
فلما تكون منتشره لما تكون انت تشوفيها
دائما حتى انا اجرت سياره كهربائيه وكانت
تريد سمارت تفاجات يعني نسيت تليفوني طبعا
فيها شاحن انت بس تحطيه يعني
ولما نزلت نسيت التليفون اعطتني نوتس انه
انت ناسيه تليفونك
فهي صارت جدا متطوره خصوصا للسيارات
الكهربائيه اللي جايه من الصين الصين من
اكبر المصنعين سبعه من كل 10 سيارات همم
تباع في الصين هي سياره كهربائيه
بس اعتقد يعني بعيده يمكن 30% يعني كل يوم
تتطور كانت يمكن قبل عشر سنوات بعيده جدا
اليوم بعيده 30%
اسعار السيارات هل ستتراجع في ظل هذه هي
الوقائع اسعار السيارات اللي صار انه
العام تراجع طلب لما رفعوا اسعار الفائده
وارتفعت تضخم الناس ما تقدر تاخذ لون
فتراجع طلب خصوصا على السيارات المستعمله
اتراكم السيارات المستعمله اليوم في ايضا
بوادر انفراج في مثل ما قلنا في مساله
شيبس او اللقاء الالكترونيات فزاد انتاج
السيارات الجديده فهذول العاملين هياثرون
هسه على اسعار السيارات المستعمله اللي من
المتوقع ان انتم تراجع بنحو 10 الى 12%
بالنسبه للاسعار همم السيارات الان
بالنسبه ليه السيارات الجديده مع زالي
يعتمد اي مشكله بالرقائق الالكترونيه اي
اغلاق مره اخرى في الصين المشكله بين
الصين وامريكا لان اليوم امريكا في مواد
معينه تحتاجها الرقائق الالكترونيه اليوم
امريكا بتحتاج وقت لتصنيعها طبعا جدا
مقرفه وهناك العديد من المواد تاتي من
بلدان مختلفه من روسيا مثلا في نوع من
الليزر هو مخصوص اللي يقص هاي الرقائق يجي
من روسيا في مكونات تيجي من امريكا وفي
مكونات الصين فالخلاف بين الصين وامريكا
مستمر على هالمساله اليوم امريكا منعه
العديد من الشركات الصدر الرقائق اذا صار
اي كلاش او اي تصادم مره اخرى اثر على
مساله الرقاقات راح ترجع ترتفع اسعار
السيارات الجديده تحديدا شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا